last question today we sort of alluded
to it in the first in the second
question is the battle between social
democracy and democratic socialism one
worth having so there are two answers to
this ideologically there is a major
difference between a social democrat who
believes in a capitalist system that is
well-regulated the coroners are sort of
sanded off to make the system work
better for more people
it sets a floor it sets the ceiling
we've talked about social democracy that
versus socializing the means of
production as an actual socialist there
is a world of difference between those
two ideas so the debate between social
democracy and democratic socialism is
not just worth having it's an incredibly
important debate that separates
drastically different world views that's
the theoretical answer now in modern
American politics we are not at risk or
we don't have the possibility of going
to democratic socialism any time soon
I've said this before when Donald Trump
gets up in front of you know the State
of the Union and during the State of the
Union address and says we will never be
a socialist country first of all he
doesn't know that things can happen over
50 years you know over 30 years over a
hundred years that Donald Trump simply
can't predict so it's a dumb thing to
say but there's also no risk that we're
about to become a socialist country the
serious reforms that are being discussed
right now around healthcare around
inequality around education public
transit housing all of these things the
risk is that we go slightly more in the
direction of social democracy and so I
believe that in in an academic sense in
a theoretical sense we should be
discussing social democracy versus
democratic socialism
in the immediate the goals for both are
probably the same if you are a social
democrat you want to get to universal
health care coverage maybe through
something like medicare for all or other
types of plans that I've mentioned if
you are a Democratic Socialist that
still is the next step for health care
which gets you closer to what you
ultimately want it's an academic debate
right now it may become a practical
debate at some point in the future in
the United States but we're not becoming
a demo
socialist country anytime soon they're
effectively no almost no democratic
socialists in positions of power even
some of them who call themselves
democratic socialists are advocating
policies of social democracy so have the
debate but the next steps are very
similar whether you're a social democrat
or a Democratic Socialist and I hope
that we can unite among making those
accomplishments a reality we've got a
great bonus show for you today become a
member or a patron to get instant access
join @ww join pakman.com or patreon.com
slash david pakman show